This episode of Dnews was proudly made possible
by the all-new 2015 Subaru Legacy.
It’s not just a sedan, it’s a Subaru.
If you’re unhappy at work, but not quite
ready to quit your job just yet - then science
has offered up an easy solution.
Adopt a plant!
Hey guys, Tara here for Dnews - and if you
work in an office with a bunch of people - then
you know just how important maintaining your
personal space is, to your sanity.
But what you might not know, is that plants
- can have a very real impact on your emotional
state of mind.
A new study from the University of Queensland,
finds that an office enriched with plants,
doesn’t just make employees happier - it
actually boosts productivity by 15%.
This is the first study to look at the long-term
effects that plants can have on the quality
of professional life.
But it’s timely, considering a lot of companies
are now starting to adopt the idea of “lean
office management,” where they strip the
office of any extraneous decorations, to reduce
distractions and so they can accommodate more
people as needed.
Most studies up until now, have concluded
that a lean office environment - is a more
productive one.
But according to this study, that may not
be entirely true.
Researchers looked at employees from 2 large
commercial offices in the UK and the Netherlands,
and monitored their productivity levels over
a 2-month period, during which time plants
were introduced into their workplace.
Employees were also surveyed on their concentration
levels, workplace satisfaction, and their
perceptions of air quality within their office.
Turns out, employees from previously “lean”
office environments, became more satisfied
with their workplace, reported increased concentration
levels, and perceived the air quality in their
offices to be better, once plants were introduced.
And the improved quality of life, led to a
more effective workplace.
According to the author of the study, adorning
your office with plants - helps employees
be more physically, mentally, and emotionally
involved in their work.
And he believes the reason for that, is that
it communicates to workers that their employer
cares about them, and their welfare.
So there you have it - if your employees hate
you, just buy them a few plants.
Or maybe stop having such a terrible workplace.
What do you guys think?
I definitely think having plants in my HOME
makes me a happier person, but what about
the office?
Let us know your thoughts in the comments
below - and as always, thank you guys for
watching.